let's go over to Zagreb with Maryse who
has a very special guest yes we are with
Vancouver Cappetta sheesh who is the
chief of staff for the Prime Minister
and he played the first move today and I
hear he's a chess player you used to
play chess
as a youngster as a youngster yes
unfortunately I don't have a much time
to continue playing chess but I try
every night at least one short blitz of
60 second just stop bullet no it's a
mental hygiene just to keep - to stay
fit very nice indeed
and we know you're a big chess fan we
know that as Croatia actually is a big
chess country and you were telling me
this goes all the way back to 1527
actually yes I'm we are very proud that
we are the only country in the world
with the chess board on its state flag
as you know and this quarter farm in the
middle of our flag dates back to 1527
when the chessboard was 8 by 8 just like
the the real chessboard so I must I can
say that there is no better place to
have this tournament and Croatia
absolutely we love that there's a
connection to st. Louis as well with
Croatia which I didn't know and you were
informing you about tell our audience
about that as well there is a very big
creation community in the States as you
know and also many Krauts are living in
Saint Louis and st. Joseph's Church in
st. Louis is one of the oldest Christian
Church in the States dating back to the
beginning of the twenty twelve centuries
absolutely incredible how does Croatia
feel having this tournament here of
course you know garry kasparov lives
here is a citizen must be something that
you're incredibly proud of yes of course
we are very proud of Gary who is a
friend who's of course the former
world champion and help a lot to bring
this tournament here in Croatia Croatia
has a long tradition in playing chess
the first tournament in Zagreb took
place in 1886 a couple of meters from
here and our Chess Federation dates back
to 1912 and we have also several very
strong chess players like even cherish
who is this year's European champion so
for for Croatia this this event is a
very important event and we are as you
have seen the Prime Minister himself was
at the opening for the first move and
the government helped a lot to make it
happen and and we hope that we will have
many other opportunities to have a green
chest or back in in in Zagreb that's
exactly what I was going to ask you next
you anticipated my question do we get a
maybe a deal signed before we leave here
oh why not love it I love the commitment
thank you so much Marko fair competish
I'm sure I'm not saying that exactly
right or maybe I am you know I'm sure we
will adopt you because of your accent
thank you very much for joining us great
work the chief of staff for the Prime
Minister and showing just how much they
love chess here in this country thank
you very much thank you for the
political so